blackboard joy is varied it mean fully
being able to express myself in any way
that I feel fit I don't know what
blackboard join me
[Music]
blackboard joy is as a feeling I can't
really put into words it's just this
internal innate visceral prior that you
know we have as black men Wow okay
challenge accepted trying to get a head
start like I'm going to show you rains
what that was cheating because that was
already built but it's fine
usual life gives you it some time time
whom it is long you know less is more
I'm sweating this is a castle I'll okay
with this
I've okay my Colosseum it's a Colosseum
so now your whole interview is gonna be
housed in a ball in the ball pit right
second to you let's do it
[Music]
my name is jabari Jacobs and I'm a
photographer
this project was important because for
one just for the culture anything for
the culture just progressive I'm for it
being just a you know a black man I just
feel like it's always important just to
visually and just have our narrative the
way it needs to be as far as being
appreciated and understood at the same
time like boy Troy is an idea that I
think essentially combats the fragility
of black masculinity what it looks like
to be excited every single day to be who
you are when I go home to Texas and I
see my family we have a fish fry on
Sunday after church
that's joy to me blackboard Joy's two
o'clock and his philosophies of life
it's called banks with his silly goofy
way enemies not being embarrassed to
actually show some type of emotion Fela
Kuti who was you know revolutionary a
radical musician in Nigeria who wanted
to you know fight for the people black
boys just this pride that black men
taken in being black
now that we have near this concept of
black boy joy we see men like dancing
and just having fun and just all this
expressing themselves and just being
colorful and just happy people if you
don't see portrayal of especially a
black boys like smiling or being happy
generally I don't know this conversation
is important just because through our
whole lives as black men we're taught to
have a rough exterior to not show a lot
of emotion not to cry growing up as a
black man even a light-skinned you know
from a young age that you are going to
be treated differently just because you
look a certain way I'm from Nigeria in
Nigeria we hold hands we we hug it was
time for us to start to create our own
narrative and when you create your own
narrative you have to attach things to
it that make it cool you have to attach
things to it that make it fun I've lived
in London in London and Europe men hug
they kissed
everyone's affectionate in America
there's this there's this toughness that
men have to have it can I think that is
a I think that is kind of maybe why you
don't see like it smiling as much
absolutely and what's wrong with that
what's wrong with vulnerability black
men were just like every other human
being we're fully realized emotional
complex messy people there's that like
clash of cultures in the way that we
thought we were supposed to be as
compared to the way we can just be
ourselves and not have to worry about
trying to fit into some preconceived
notions about what masculinity actually
is no I don't think being a joyful black
man or boy makes you vulnerable
me personally I don't because I like I
said I look at everything in a positive
light when I was younger I did now that
I'm older I think it's kind of like a
superpower Oh being able to be joyful
have Joy's kind of like a confidence
builder no I don't think that being a
joyful black boy makes you vulnerable
but I do think that vulnerability gives
you more opportunity to be
a joyful black boy I remember when I
first came to this country as a young
boy I was ten and I was in the theater
class and we sat down in the in the room
not it's opium and I realized that a lot
of black boys always gave a little gap
between each other when they sat down I
don't understand what that was about
I think being black and having joy is it
should just be something that um
something that we cut
so with that being said hey the black
males well let's do it they can't get in
here though cuz it's not even more room
I try to make sure I use colors I use
men of color in ways that haven't been
seen before and I use a lot of bright
colors that people don't typically do
like recently I shot a guy and I like
Dada everything dyed his hands pink just
as I thought it'd be dope to do I try to
always just do things that are just
outside of the norm and also I feel like
it helps to show us as black men in a
different light we don't all just wear
black hoodies and you know keep our
faces tight we do smile we do like
bright colors and people need to see
that but most bright colors would be
really well on Brown scanning this
became one of my favorite subjects to
shoot
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]